Je te donne 10 secondes d'avance
et vous avez besoin d'un costume de super-héros oui
beau cru mais de quoi venez-vous
robe de dysenterie
comment dit-on que les fonds deviennent
Invisible
Je ne me remets pas du garçon invisible et
Maintenant, vous devez aider les gens intéressants
qui êtes-vous
un fantôme que ta mère t'a transmis
son don et s'est sacrifiée pour te sauver
ils savent des choses sur nous
peut-être qu'il y a des gars avec certains
talent particulier ai déjà commencé à
découvrir la potentialité du corps
la division sait que tu es ici qui tu es mais
peut vraiment exister
J'ai attendu ça toute ma vie
temps pour qu'on te voie